on the daily wire you talked about how
one problem with our culture is that we
worship celebrities but earlier when you
wave to our table I'm pretty sure
everyone was about to faint
so is do you think that worshiping
celebrities in this is in a conservative
setting has almost been a positive thing
for spurring the movement well I mean
what I always hope is the reason that
people like my stuff is because they
like my stuff they like how I think and
they like how to express arguments you
know none of you know me personally for
all you know I could be an ax murderer
so when it comes to I'm not but but when
it comes to celebrity worship I think
that we tend to granite my problem is
not you liking something somebody says
what they do like if you want to be a
big Chris Pratt ranks do you think he's
a great actor or you want to be a and by
the way his message the MTV Awards is
fantastic or if you want to be a family
to what he said there I think that's
great what I don't like is when we start
extending the worship of celebrity into
areas where celebrities have no business
speaking right so I don't care well I'm
glad the Kanye West said that he's
open-minded but I prank Li do not care
very much about Kanye West's opinion in
politics because I don't think he knows
anything and I don't really care what
Kim Kardashian has to say about pardons
for drug dealers cuz I don't think she
knows anything and she was to bring an
expert in to be the president and talk
about it that's one thing but we have a
tendency in our culture to worship
celebrities not for the things that they
are good at which i think is i don't
like the word worship but but to like
celebrities or or to look up to
celebrities for the things that they're
good at that's fine
remember when I was growing up I was
violinist I was a classically trained
basically constant level violinist and I
used to be a Big East idolized Jascha
Heifetz he's the greatest violinist in
history and I read and idolized him for
his sin of personal interactions
idolized entities great violinist I
think that's totally normal and totally
fine I think it's another thing to say
that celebrities know things that they
do not so if you're looking at me for
basketball tips I would say that's a
waste of time if you're looking to me
for books to read I think that's a
pretty good use of your time